hey Carmen yah nein ich mache nur
spaß hey kick hey Milo zuallererst Milo
du bist ein toller musiker ich liebe deine
musik sie ist wirklich toll ich habe drei
fragen an dich die erste ist ob
du deine ideen für deine songs bekommst
Ich denke zum Beispiel an den Priester, den ich
religiös oder so singe, und
warum hast du über eine Technologie berichtet, gibt es
eine besondere Geschichte dahinter und das
dritte ist unser, welche Art von Ziel
möchtest du in der Zukunft erreichen
?  einen besonderen Preis zu gewinnen oder es
mit einem besonderen Künstler zu machen oder so, ja,
danke für deine Arme und einen tollen
Tag, alle drei, ja, also, oh ja, der Priester,
das Lied, auf unbestimmte Zeit bewaffnet, nicht
religiös, für mich. Ich habe das Lied, der
Priester, geschrieben, weil für  Für mich ist es ein Lied über das
Erwachsenwerden und darüber,
die Entscheidungen zu hinterfragen, die man getroffen hat,
und ich weiß nicht warum, aber
ich habe mit diesem
Bild gespielt, bei dem ich viel Melancholie
und Sympathie empfand  Empathie für
zum Beispiel jemanden kennen  wie diese Figur
, die ich für dieses Lied Peter Vanderholt erfunden habe.
Ich nenne ihn in meinem Lied, er ist 68,
und ich habe gerade diese Figur entwickelt,
und es wurde wirklich jemand Echtes, und er
tat mir so leid, dass er
am Ende am Ende war  von ihm oder kurz vor dem
Ende seines Lebens, dass er über
alles nachdachte, was er
das ganze Leben zuvor getan hatte, und mich hat das
irgendwie berührt, denke ich, und deshalb
wollte ich ein Lied darüber schreiben,
dass es nicht die Religion ist  Dinge wie
die Tatsache, dass er seinen Glauben verliert, ähm
, das ist nur ein Teil eines Teils dieses
Liedes für mich, für mich ist es nur eine Schicht
und es ist auch ein Lied für mich über das
Erwachsenwerden, es ist sogar ein Lied über
Väter und Söhne, es ist ein Lied  Es ist ja,
das habe ich mit diesem Song versucht zu sagen
, also hat das definitiv nichts mit Religion zu tun. Die
zweite Frage war, warum ich es
analog gemacht
habe  es ist
eine frage ich  Ich glaube, ich habe oft geantwortet,
aber ich habe keine Probleme, es dir noch einmal zu sagen.
Ich habe gerade dieses Lied ausgewählt. Ich habe nicht.
Ich habe nicht.
Ich habe nicht darüber nachgedacht  ursprünglicher
Fünftel einer Technologie so gut, aber
alles, was ich wusste, war, dass ich die
Melodie im Refrain mochte, dass ich dachte,
es wäre wirklich lustig, dass es in diesen
Texten um Cybersex ging
und dass du es weißt, weil du es warst
Ich weiß in der Verpackung eines R&B-Songs zwischen Justin Timberlake und 50 Cent, dass aus diesem Grund nicht viele Leute darauf geachtet haben, was sie singen, also wollte ich nur ein
bisschen Spaß daran haben, einen Song wie diesen
so einen Macho-Song zu übersetzen  Entfernen Sie diesen magischen
Charakter aus diesem Song und versuchen Sie einfach so
zu tun, als ob es
einer meiner eigenen Songs gewesen wäre. Das ist der Grund, warum
ich diesen Song ausgewählt habe, und dann die dritte
Frage, mit der ich versuche, was mein Ziel ist
Ich habe irgendwie aufgehört,
mir Ziele zu setzen  Selbst, weil das Leben, aber nicht das
Leben, aber nur du weißt, Tage und Monate
und Jahre so unvorhersehbar sind, dass du
weißt, dass ich nicht einmal weiß, dass du weißt, was
in dir passieren wird, weißt du zum Beispiel innerhalb von sechs
Monaten, also versuche ich einfach,
einen Tag eine Woche zu nehmen  Zu einer Zeit versuche ich,
konsequent zu sein und die Entscheidungen, die ich treffe, und
wie ich bestimmte Dinge angehe, aber wenn
ich zum Beispiel jedes Jahr
zurückblicken und auf ein Jahr zurückblicken kann, in dem ich neue Dinge ausprobiert habe, in
denen ich, wie Sie wissen, Fortschritte bei
anderen gemacht habe  Ebenen als Musiker, aber auch
als Person, das ist für mich das, was Sie wissen, das
ist das, was für mich mein Ziel ist. Ich denke,
die nächsten Jahre
sind
Sie